from 2010 to 2020 frank fritz hosted the
reality tv show
american pickers on the history channel
alongside mike wolff
the series featured the two traveling
around the u.s on what the network calls
a mission to recycle
america which required them to obtain
and restore antiques and other forgotten
relics while meeting their owners and
hearing their stories
pritz's last episode aired in march 2020
and the show has gone on without him its
21st season ended in august 2020
and the 22nd season is ongoing until
recently the history channel and the
crew behind american pickers hadn't said
anything about fritz's disappearance
from the show leading fans on a facebook
fan page to ask
demand and wonder about what was going
on behind the scenes
previous speculation and comments from
those involved in the series had
centered on the coven 19 pandemic
back surgery and the state of fritz's
health thanks to a july 19th interview
with the sun the mystery of his
disappearance has finally been clarified
it turns out there's some truth to the
previously announced reasons that
explain why he stepped away
he told the outlet i didn't leave the
show
i finished shooting and then i had a
little back surgery and the pandemic
came
however it turns out there's a little
more to fritz's departure than that
in the sun article fritz admitted that
he and wolf who have known each other
for 40 years and can quote
finish each other's sentences have been
on the outs for a while
he told the newspaper i haven't talked
to mike in two years
he knew my back was messed up but he
didn't call me up and ask how i was
doing
that's just how it is although he did
not reveal the exact
cause of the feud if that's what it
amounts to at another point during the
interview fritz lamented
i don't know why he's behaving like that
towards me it's clear however that the
two have dealt with tensions brought on
by the fame they've experienced
fritz said the show is quote tilted
towards wolf
one thousand percent and that he himself
is more of a
regular old guy he hasn't stepped too
far out of the spotlight though the
reality star who has been open about his
battle with crohn's disease since 2013
made news in the meantime when he lost
65 pounds
despite the long hiatus he said i would
like to come back to the show but
we will see i was doing it for 11 years
but there is a lot of controversy going
on right now
however fritz also admitted that to
resume his hosting duties after not
speaking to wolfe for two years would be
hard his final word on the matter was
it's up to the network whether i come
back on the show
it ain't gonna affect me one bit sadly
it doesn't look like frank fritz will
get his wish mike wolfe himself
finally confirmed on july 21 that fritz
will not be returning to american
pickers in an instagram post that
obliquely addressed the matter
wolfe called his former co-host a
brother instead of his time with fritz
the journey that frank danny and i
started back in 2009
like all of life has come with its highs
and lows blessings and
challenges but it has also been the most
rewarding
he concluded i will miss frank just like
all of you and i pray for the very best
and all good things for him
on the next part of his journey this
definitely implies he won't be back a
fact
that quote sources close to the show's
production
also confirmed to tmz earlier this week
there had been speculation that wolfe
wanted to replace his former co-host
with his brother robbie wolf
talking to the sun fritz himself said i
think mike wants to get his brother
robbie in there to replace me
tmz however reports that the show's
producers have no plans for robbie to
come on board
some fans have said via social media
comments that they'll stop watching the
show as a result of the removal
whether that sentiment is widespread
enough to affect the series ratings
remains to be seen for now the 11th year
of american pickers continues to air
monday nights at 9pm eastern on the
history channel
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite reality tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss
a single one